Welcome back to human emotion.
Today we will conclude our section on emotion and health by probing into the
role of psychotherapy in alleviating emotional suffering.
In other words,
can we heal our emotions through the lens of therapy,
and if so,
what are the active ingredients of a successful emotion related intervention?
Looking at our roadmap today,
we'll see that we have the honor of having a very special guest lecture on this
topic from Doctor Stefan Hoffman and eminent scholar in the field of emotion in
psychotherapy.
This will be followed by takeaway questions and our expert interview
today for our guests lecture,
Dr Stefan Hoffman will be speaking with us.
He is a professor of psychology at the Department of Psychology at Boston
University where he directs the psychotherapy and emotion research laboratory.
His main research focus is on the mechanisms of treatment change,
translating discoveries from neuroscience into clinical applications,
emotion regulation strategies,
and cultural expressions of psychopathology,
including social anxiety disorder.
He has published more than 200 scientific articles and 15 books and is the
president of the Association for Behavioral and cognitive therapies.
And president elect of the International Association of cognitive psychotherapy.
He also the editor of cognitive therapy and research associate editor of the
Journal of Consulting and clinical psychology and a member of the Scientific
Advisory Board for the Anxiety Disorders Association of America.
Dr. Hoffman is also the recipient of the 2012 award for excellence in
contributions to CBT by the Aaron T.
Beck Institute for Cognitive Studies at Assumption College.
So it is my honor now to hear a very special guest lecture from Doctor Stefan
Hoffman.
Hi,
uh,
my name is Stefan Hoffman.
I'm professor of psychology at Boston University.
I am going to talk about emotion in psychotherapy.
Emotions are essential,
uh,
in mental disorders,
and um,
in the treatment of mental disorders.
Uh,
in fact,
this goes to the very hard to some very fundamental fundamental questions as to
how the mind and the body are,
uh,
associated,
renewed the card.
Um,
uh,
early on,
um,
uh,
claim that the soul,
the mind and the body are two distinct entities.
The mind being entirely,
uh,
immaterial,
unique to humans and,
uh,
links to cognitions and consciousness.
Whereas the body,
uh,
is entirely material and comparable to a machine that,
animals,
uh,
health,
in the bodily changes caused emotions with which they are associated.
And this is an issue that,
uh,
we will be discussing also,
in,
uh,
in later theories or William James in particular,
had a similar idea as to how mind and the body relates.
However,
he,
um,
assumes monistic view in that mental actions may be uniform in absolutely,
uh,
to,
function of brain action varying escalator later various and being to the brain
action as to s effect to cost.
It's what he wrote in his principles of psychology of the very first
introduction into psychology textbook.
Uh,
he sees emotions as secondary to a specific physiological symptoms,
sensations.
So we feel sad,
uh,
because we cry,
we feel happy because we laughed.
This has become known as the James Lang theory.
Alternative to that theory was to a notion by say,
Schachter and singer in that,
um,
uh,
it is to cognitive appraisal,
the cognitive interpretation of these,
uh,
of symptoms that,
determine what emotional response we have.
And this is an issue that,
uh,
has become a prominent,
point in modern theories.
Sigmund Freud,
uh,
thought the saw emotions as a safety valve that lets off psychic steam and the
events that caused these emotions that are stirred up,
uh,
by some instinctual drive levy do all the tenitus,
there tends to be repressed.
Now,
Skinner,
uh,
didn't really,
put much emphasis on emotions.
He thought that all human behavior,
including La Language and also thoughts,
mental processes are shaped by and maintained by an arrangement of past and
present reinforcer.
So he thought his stimulus leads to response and it doesn't really matter how
this leads to a response.
Important thing that it does lead to a response in all actions in humans are,
uh,
a,
um,
a chain of such a stimulus,
response,
relationships,
emotions he's saw as private experiences and inaccessible to observation.
And therefore we shouldn't bother studying them in great detail.
Now,
along came norm Chomsky,
a sack of linguist,
uh,
who,
specifically criticized,
uh,
Skinner's,
verbal behavior,
a book that he published back in 1959 and he thought he thought that a
conditioning radical behaviorism cannot explain how language is acquired in
children.
And also universal grammar,
uh,
is a,
it's inconsistent with the notion that Skinner had.
Instead,
he thought language is a product of a universally in need.
Uh,
ability,
uh,
that is that all humans have a,
this marks the beginning of the cognitive revolution.
And from a left to right,
we have a number of proponents,
John Piaget,
uh,
on the very left,
Aaron T.
Beck and Albert Ellis and Arnold Lazarus,
uh,
and,
Albert Bandura and a more modern theorists,
David Clark.
Uh,
they,
uh,
all,
um,
uh,
evolve these thinkers,
um,
had their,
had their ideas evolved as a result of this cognitive revolution.
What is the cognitive theory of emotion and psychological disorders?
The cognitive model can be,
um,
quite simply explained,
uh,
by some ancient philosophers and also other,
philosophical thinkers and writers,
Epictetus road main,
or not move by things,
but the view they take of them.
Um,
so in other words,
it is not the emotional response.
That emotional response is not caused directly by the stimulus,
but rather by the way you view,
you praise the stimulus.
So cognitive appraisal as an important mediator between the stimulus and the
emotional response.
Similarly,
uh,
Marcus a really is a road.
If you are distressed by anything external,
the pain is not due to the thing itself,
but to your estimate of it and this you have the power to revoke at any moment.
To put it another way,
the distress and pain,
the emotional response is not caused by the stimulus itself,
by back,
by the cognitive appraisal.
Uh,
Shakespeare road.
There's nothing either good or bad,
but thinking makes it so,
in other words,
the,
uh,
your judgment of whether or not something is good or bad.
It's not due to the stimulus itself,
but due to the thinking,
the cognitive appraisal,
a more modern,
uh,
and more complex,
idea,
uh,
or translating this very basic idea until modern thinking.
Um,
uh,
we have a,
a,
uh,
depending on a particular,
belief that people have,
um,
uh,
a particular trigger situation is being interpreted in a certain way in
psychological disorders.
This is often a expressed as a maladaptive cognitive,
uh,
thought kind of appraisal and attentional processes are also involved,
there guide the person toward certain stimuli,
ignoring others.
This then leads to physiological symptoms,
subjective experience it and behavioral responses which,
uh,
often feed back to the beliefs.
And these,
uh,
the cognitive appraisal said we have,
this is a very generic model.
And let me explain it to you more concretely.
Uh,
using two particular,
uh,
psychological disorders.
Let's take spider phobia.
A person with spider phobia might have the belief that spiders are dangerous and
the person might skim the environment.
Uh,
um,
examining whether there are spiders around a certain attentional process.
And if there is in fact a,
an object that might look like a spider,
um,
this would then lead,
could lead to the,
to the belief this ics by them,
despite of will attack me leading them to heart racing and filling us off fear
and disgust.
And the person wants to avoid the situation and get out of the situation.
Um,
another example might be panic disorder.
Uh,
so a person might have the belief that I have to be in control of my body at any
time.
Uh,
as a result,
I focus on parts of my body that I think might be out of control,
such as my heart.
Uh,
and,
uh,
if I feel now my,
my heart is beating fast,
uh,
Eh,
I might have the belief that I have a heart attack,
which then leads to a further increase in heart rate,
uh,
subjective feelings of terror and distress and,
and maybe,
uh,
a,
a desire to get out of the situation or Toya Hospital.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
a medical doctors around in case an emergency is happening.
This,
then again can feed back to the very idea that,
uh,
something is something might be wrong with me and I have,
I am not in control of my body at any moment.
Now,
uh,
this is a rather complex,
a picture,
oops.
Uh,
this is a rather complex picture.
however,
it exemplifies a number of strategies psychologists have been using to target,
uh,
depending on the psychological,
symptoms and syndrome of specific aspects of this cognitive model.
Um,
for example,
um,
uh,
a person might,
um,
might be,
uh,
encouraged,
to,
to choose different situations,
stuck in the simplest case,
a person with spider phobia might choose to Alaska where there no spiders
around.
Therefore,
the trigger is not there anymore.
Now,
obviously,
they are,
uh,
more,
um,
uh,
this is not the most effective way of treating spider phobia.
Other ways are a psychoeducation cognitive restructuring.
You might question some of these basic ideas that the person has a of spiders,
in fact,
dangerous.
Um,
uh,
have us,
has a spider ever attacked you,
et cetera.
Uh,
so psychoeducation,
cognitive restructuring is to core of contemporary cognitive behavior therapy.
Um,
uh,
attention.
More modern approaches have been found to be quite effective,
but also relaxation can help in certain for certain disorders.
Even breathing,
retraining,
uh,
particularly,
effective.
Our exposure,
uh,
therapy,
procedures.
Also acceptance procedure in which we accept our feelings rather than trying to
avoid,
uh,
we often talk about that in terms of experiential avoidance,
which I try not to have these feelings,
but by encouraging the person to embrace and to become comfortable with feelings
of anxiety,
uh,
the,
this vicious cycle can be disrupted.
A behavioral activation behavior modification are other additional strategies
that can be used for certain disorders.
In particular,
depression.
Mindfulness Meditation is a more modern approach.
Uh,
in fact,
it isn't.
It is borrowed from,
um,
uh,
the Buddhist literature,
which is obviously a very old,
but we have adopted dead in contemporary cognitive behavior therapy,
uh,
to encourage the person to,
um,
uh,
to take a stance of nonjudgmental awareness.
Um,
and,
uh,
and this often also can disrupt these,
this vicious cycle.
Um,
in particular exposure,
uh,
therapy,
is,
uh,
is a,
is a highly effective form of a treatment for anxiety disorders.
There are just a few,
um,
uh,
ways or how people deal with their distress.
And,
uh,
this obviously gives psychologists a way to interfere,
and to,
uh,
to modify these maladaptive behaviors.
People with panic disorder might carry cell phones with them,
uh,
or uh,
people with obsessive compulsive disorder.
My carrier,
good luck,
good luck charm or take medication carrying sunglasses can water bottle having a
bible attend holding a drink.
All of this are,
uh,
what we call safety signals that makes the person feel in a safe place even
though it obviously doesn't make a difference.
Um,
behavioral avoidance strategies might be,
uh,
might include avoiding eye contact,
avoiding drinking coffee because it leads to heightened arousal that panic
disorder patients dislike.
Attempting to control the breathing,
um,
uh,
avoiding exercise,
avoiding touching a single or procrastination.
Uh,
all of these are examples of behavioral avoidance strategies for a various
anxiety disorders.
Cognitive avoidance can in main clued distraction,
tuning out,
reassuring yourself,
pushing away thoughts,
pushing away memories,
thinking positive thoughts,
which is not what we believe is cognitive therapy,
but thinking positive thoughts.
It's actually maladaptive way of dealing with your,
uh,
distress,
warring,
rumination and thought suppression.
All of that,
uh,
we consider a cognitive form of cognitive avoidance.
Uh,
this is very much consistent with,
um,
emotion theories,
contemporary emotion theories,
which assume that emotions arise as a result of,
um,
of focusing your attention on certain,
uh,
certain stimuli and a maladaptive appraisal of these situations,
which then leads to the,
the emotional response.
And you can,
um,
modify these,
uh,
these,
these parts of this emotion regulation process,
uh,
at various stages by modifying the situation by,
differential,
uh,
deployment of attention by changing cognitions and buy a chain,
modifying the response,
we actually distinguish,
um,
and deceit and focused and responds focus strategies.
Cognitive appraisal is premier Li a response focus strategy.
Uh,
so far we have not spoken much about positive effect yet.
Positive ethic is an important,
uh,
dimension in our discussion.
Uh,
positive ethic can both be adaptive.
And maladaptive,
uh,
for this discussion,
I primarily want to focus on the adaptive on the good parts of the positive
ethic dimension.
Uh,
certain triggers lead to an effective style.
People differ in the way they respond to situations.
Some people tend to respond more positively,
others more negatively to a very similar situation.
This is obviously linked to a particular diaphysis to a particular genetic
makeup.
A person has a negative effect is being disregulated and can result in emotional
disorders such as an anxiety disorder.
Uh,
a,
a positive effect,
uh,
tends to counter the effects of a negative of negative effect.
And we,
in psychotherapy,
we have not focused enough on capitalizing on,
on positive ethic.
In fact,
uh,
certain strategies including mindfulness strategies may just enhance a positive
ethic,
which as a result,
uh,
inhibits negative ethic and also,
um,
uh,
has a beneficial effect on,
in the emotional response.
Now,
uh,
let me share with you with some,
um,
neuroscience approaches did we've been using to examine this puzzle of emotion,
uh,
cognitive appraisal and,
in,
in more detail in particular,
we've been examining a prediction of,
uh,
of psychiatric disorders.
Uh,
and for this purpose we might examine the patient's brain activation,
um,
right before,
uh,
before they initiate a particular treatment.
Um,
in,
uh,
in this particular study we found that,
depending on a particular task,
they have to,
had to view certain faces and decide whether or not they saw a particular face
before the parade of the activation of certain brain areas that are used in
processing phases.
The better the person will respond to treatment,
to cognitive behavior treatment,
suggesting that,
uh,
you need to be able to process information and avoidance strategies that,
tends to,
uh,
distract you and not processed information works against you when it comes to
treatment to,
uh,
we can quite accurately predict who will respond to treatment and will not
respond to treatment based on once a brain activation prior to treatment.
So,
um,
in discharge is an example of a particular measure that is used to measure to,
to assess social anxiety.
Uh,
the,
uh,
on the x axis depicted is the actual change of,
in this particular measure,
low carb,
the Libra with social anxiety scale on the y axis of what would be predicted
based on,
uh,
once brain activation,
to a particular task.
And as you can see,
there's a very strong relationship of 0.66.
Uh,
now psychotherapy is a form of learning,
a rather complex form of learning and perhaps we can enhance the learning by,
uh,
by augmenting the process that happens during this learning process.
Uh,
in particular,
um,
uh,
I'm not going to obviously describe all of this in detail.
This is just to depict the complexity of what is happening during,
uh,
this what is going on,
on the neuronal cellular level.
Uh,
when learning occurs.
In essence,
there are,
uh,
there are two cells.
You have seen this,
uh,
such a slide of a synopsis.
Uh,
in particular the hormone,
uh,
the neurotransmitter glutamate is quite a important in this learning process.
And as a,
as a,
um,
as you learn something new,
glutamate is being released in the synaptic gap that binds to the respective
receptor side units.
Um,
but this,
there needs to be sufficient,
uh,
release of glutamate for this to happen.
Um,
and we know that once,
um,
once enough signaling occurs,
there are complex processes.
Uh,
they're not only lead to the building of news receptors at the particular
synapsis,
but also to adjacent,
uh,
new receptors at adjacent synopsis.
Uh,
in other words,
uh,
learning has a positive cascading effect.
If learning is optimal,
if learning is suboptimal,
not much will be happening at the synopsis.
Uh,
uh,
just to depict it more simplistically,
when glutamate,
this particular neurotransmitter I just described and glycine a bind together at
this,
uh,
receptive side unit,
we call it an NMD receptor and methyl diaspora,
Todd receptor calcium ions come from the outside to inside of the cell,
which then leads to longterm potentiation,
which is the,
uh,
biological basis for,
um,
for learning
a decide glycerin is a particular molecule,
uh,
that,
that binds to this the glycine receptor side unit that leads to greater influx
of calcium leading to greater longterm potentiation.
We have shown and others have shown that if you give decent grocerant in small,
a very small dose,
which of a substance it happens to be also an antibiotic,
but you give such a small amount that there's,
that uh,
uh,
the antibiotic,
Bill below the,
the action of the antibiotic property,
uh,
if you give as such a small amount of,
of the sacral certain,
uh,
the,
the learning that happens during exposure therapy is being enhanced.
Uh,
in other words,
the person learns a lot faster,
whatever they would usually learn,
which takes him a lot.
Uh,
uh,
it,
the,
the learning is a lot faster for those who receive the Sackler Seron versus
those who received top placebo.
So to conclude,
the most effective contemporary psychotherapy is cognitive behavior therapy.
And it's founded on the idea that,
uh,
we appraised a stimulus in our environment,
in our body.
And this appraisal can be maladaptive causes us,
uh,
emotional distress.
And by modifying this cognitive appraisal,
we can effectively treat psychiatric disorders.
Cognitive appraisal,
therefore is a very powerful emotion regulation strategy,
but it is not the only emotion regulation strategy.
More modern approaches,
uh,
incorporate other emotion regulation strategies such as mindfulness techniques.
And I have not spoken much about that.
These strategies are,
can compliment and enhance traditional cognitive behavior therapy and most
exciting,
I think,
uh,
are more,
modern neuroscience approaches that can be used to further augment and also
predict treatment outcome.
Okay.
And if you'd like to know more about these issues,
you might find it in this book.
Introduction to modern CBT.
Thank you for your attention.
We will now move to our takeaway questions.
Our first takeaway question asks,
what does the traditional cognitive model of psychology and what are the three
temporal components of the cognitive model discussed today by Dr Stefan Hoffman
too.
Can you describe the components of the generic CBT model proposed by Hoffman?
How does it apply to panic disorder and spider phobia?
And three,
can you describe the components of the emotion disregulation,
model of mood and anxiety disorders proposed by Hoffman and colleagues in 2012
we'll now move to our expert interview.
Today we will be speaking with Dr. Roy Baumeister.
Dr Baumeister is currently a professor of psychology at Florida State
University.
He received his phd in social psychology from Princeton in 1978 and did a
postdoctoral fellowship and sociology at UC Berkeley.
Dr Baumeister's research spans multiple topics including self identity,
self regulation,
interpersonal rejection and the need to belong,
sexuality and gender aggression,
self esteem meaning and self presentation.
Dr Baumeister's received research grants from the National Institutes of health
and from the Templeton Foundation.
He has over 500 publication and 31 books.
The Institute for scientific information lists him among the handful of the most
cited and most influential psychologists in the world.
He has received lifetime achievement awards from the Society for personality and
Social Psychology,
the international society for self and identity,
and the William James Award from the association for Psychological Science.
So I now turn to our experts in emotion interview with Dr. Roy Baumeister on
self regulation and emotion.